[Music]
in just a few days time I have to cook a
traditional Cambodian menu for royalty
I'm in the busy capital city burn on
Penh visiting a cookery school dedicated
to re-establishing traditional Cambodian
cuisine but what makes this place
remarkable other students thousands of
orphans and Street kids have passed
through his doors these children are the
legacy of over 15 years of Khmer Rouge
rule and civil war nice to see me know
the woman in charge has invited me to
join her class okay I tell you what she
doesn't mess anyone inside the Hat
please today
she's teaching an old style cambodian
pork and pumpkin curry
Nina you're scary
Louis Nina's the project matriarch
she's nurtured hundreds of children to
create some real cooking Talent
I'm teamed up with eighteen-year-old
cippec his parents died 10 years ago
and he spent time living on the streets
today he's the project's prize pupil but
when it comes to Cambodian cuisine I
still feel like a novice once the
complex spice paste is made we hit the
hobs
and start cooking 18 years of age he's
been cooking for three years so excited
about the flavors the smell it's amazing
okay five two coconut it looks simple
but getting the balance of flavors is
tricky to master every time I turn
around you're there you're watching me
like I'm like I'm your worst student yes
finally that all-important sweet touch
palm sugar then we leave the curry to
cook okay good excellent once that
Curry's are done the class ends with a
taste test right Nina
here we go fingers crossed
yeah that's it means good luck okay and
now and now your toes seriously a person
8 out of 10 not enough my pants are
there no enough palm sugar please please
eight out of ten yeah I'm not going to
argue with her that's for sure
damn eight out of ten she's right
I've said right deafie needs more parma
sugar without a doubt because it's just
a bit too spicy it's back to the hob and
in with another ladle of palm sugar to
get it absolutely spot-on
the project doesn't only train kids to
be chefs it feeds the city's
underprivileged children to it's
lunchtime and a curry is on the menu
because it just has arrived now and got
luckily aged them I mean they're young
this project is a real inspiration
they've got a foot of lump in my throat
I thought when they said Street kids I'm
thinking teenagers but no in walk you
know fifty yards three four five year
olds I'm leaving with huge respect for
the work they do here but first I want
to make my classmates effec an offer I
hope he can't refuse
I've got a very very important dinner
for members of the royal family and I'm
so impressed with what you've done this
morning I would like this amazing
students to come and help me cook would
you like to come and cook with me would
like to town yes yes thank you thank you
amazing keep up the good work yes I've
got a sous chef and a great career esse
P but I plan one final excursion to
ensure we really impress Realty